[Music]
all you need to make a star is hydrogen
gravity and time gravity pulls the dust
and gas into a giant swirling vortex
gravity brings matter together and when
you bring matter together and you
squeeze things into smaller spaces they
necessarily heat up it's a simple law of
chemistry you can press something you
drive the temperature up over hundreds
of thousands of years the cloud gets
thicker and forms a giant spinning disk
bigger than our entire solar system at
its center gravity crushes the gas into
a super dense super hot ball
pressure builds until huge jets of gas
burst out from the center
but it really shows you how violent a
process star-formation is
these Jets are many light-years across
something is literally accelerating
material very fast across unimaginable
distances
[Music]
gravity keeps the pressure on sucking in
gas and dust particles that smash into
each other generating more and more heat
over the next half a million years the
young star gets smaller brighter and
hotter temperatures at its core reach 15
million degrees
only at that mind-boggling temperature
can atoms of gas begin to fuse together
releasing massive amounts of energy
[Music]
[Music]
and just like that a star is born
[Music]